die gesamte nordhalbkugel ist heiß zum
ersten mal haben klimawissenschaftler
diese situation konkret mit dem
klimawandel in zusammenhang gebracht und
jetzt wurde eine studie veröffentlicht
die einen wirklich dramatischen wandel
vorhersagt demnach stehen wir vor einer
eiszeit herzlich willkommen zur blick
zum science fiction
gestern waren die nachrichten wieder
voll davon waldbrände in kalifornien ist
der größte waldbrand der geschichte des
landes ausgebrochen 100 15.000 hektar
sind inzwischen verbrannt mehr als 1000
häuser wurden zerstört 14.000
feuerwehrleute sind im einsatz
das feuer ist nicht unter kontrolle es
wird frühestens mit dem 15 august dafür
gerechnet bis es eben kontrolliert
werden kann
das sind wirklich riesige flächen die
dort zerstört werden und es wird jedes
jahr schlimmer wir müssen wohl in
zukunft damit rechnen dass große flächen
abbrennen es wird bei solchen
temperaturen und sommertrockenheit
selbst hier in mitteleuropa oder sogar
skandinavien wir haben darüber berichtet
nicht mehr zu vermeiden sein flüsse
trocknen hieraus ernten sind total
gering und so weiter und so fort und
jetzt haben klimaforscher und forscherin
bei dieser entwicklung so genannte kit
systeme analysiert das sind systeme die
werden ihre veränderungen durch den
klimawandel angestoßen wird den
klimawandel noch weiter beschleunigen
zum beispiel ist dass das schwindende
eis in der arktis wodurch weniger
sonnenlicht zurück ins weltall
reflektiert wird permafrostböden die
wenn sie tauen das klimagas methan frei
geben die abholzung des
amazonas-regenwaldes wodurch weniger co2
in sauerstoff umgewandelt wird
methanhydrate am meeresboden die wenn
sie tauen auch methan frei geben und und
und der effekt all dieser chip systeme
könnte wie bei dominosteinen
funktionierenden system für system kippt
und zwar ganz ohne dass es noch mehr co2
in der atmosphäre bedürfte johann rock
strömen direktor des stockholm
resilience centers und co-direktor also
baldiger co direktor des potsdam
instituts für klimafolgenforschung pik
zitat wird einer von ihnen gekippt
schiebt dieses element die erde auf
einen weiteren punkt zu und durch diese
kettenreaktion wird der klimawandel dann
automatisch immer mehr verstärkt zum
beispiel könnte der verlust des eises in
der west
axis schon so weit fortgeschritten sein
dass der kipp punkt dort schon
überschritten sei meint hans joachim
schellnhuber vom pk dann würde die
antarktis umfangreich abschmelzen
die studie hält als folge eine heiße
zeit für wahrscheinlich die erde würde
sich dann um vier bis fünf grad erwärmen
und der meeresspiegel um zehn bis 60
meter steigen weite landstriche der erde
müssten verlassen werden eine
flüchtlingsbewegung unbekannten ausmaßes
käme in gang
bei welchen temperaturen diese
kettenreaktion der kipp systeme
allerdings beginnt das kann heute
niemand sagen
trotzdem waren forscher und
forscherinnen davor dieses risiko zu
ignorieren die politik muss also endlich
mal wirklich reagieren um konkretere
schritte unternehmen dass wir es vor
kurzem berichtet haben das klima risiko
fleischproduktion ignoriert wird ist
schlichtweg unverantwortlich wenn ihr
kein video dazu und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich
bei whatsapp darum geht ihr die etwas
unzuverlässige abo box hier auf youtube
und er verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
persönlich von neben upload und zwar
noch vor allen anderen täglich
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klick zum social media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social
media welt dafür da klicken aber nicht
die genau die glocke vergessen hier geht
es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
sommer 2018 unser kampf gegen die hitze
bis dann bleibt dran